[Musique]
bonjour à tous nouvelle édition spéciale
les 12-13 sur france 3 au lendemain
d'une soirée littoral à suspense
regardez sur quinze députés de bourgogne
dix porte désormais les couleurs de la
république en marche celle des
républicains quatre députés et une seule
socialiste cécile untermaier en saône et
loire
nous détaillerons et les résultats dans
ce journal notons également que douze
députés n'ont jamais occupé cette
fonction et que seuls trois sortants ont
été réélus
parmi les nouveaux visages celui de
yolaine de courson dans la 4e
circonscription de la côte d'or c'est
celle du nord du département jusqu alors
maire de la petite commune d'ars en près
de montbard elle a battu charles
barrière candidats elle est rude et y
51,3 contre 48,7 la soirée d'une
nouvelle élue avec amélie doit et
isabelle rivière
à tout à l'heure 17 heures
violaine de course on abandonne sa
mairie à ses adjoints maire d'une
commune de 73 habitants il lui est
difficile de prendre la température sur
place
en route pour la préfecture de dijon la
tension monte
les premiers résultats commencent à
tomber c'est serré très serré dans le
châtillonnais il semblerait que du côté
de sainte colombe et où 200 têtes à
châtillon les records 320 de retard
on va voir c'est le nombre de global qui
va compter au final
en chemin elle ne résiste pas à vérifier
par elle-même ce sera ma lin une commune
de 750 habitants déjà conséquente dans
cette circonscription rurale
il ya une grosse différence qui a pas
autant par ailleurs les blancs bravo
balle a alors sans j'en ai pas de chez
super dense mais j'ai pas les villes ça
s'est vraiment passé où je risque se
cherche à lui a pas des grosses villes
voilà mais en chemin
tout s'accélère c'est génial on va on va
vous la rumeur se confirme le maire de
châtillon n'a finalement pas appelé à
voter pour le candidat de la droite 500
voix d'avant sa fatigue
c'est donc presque sereinement que
yolaine de course ont rejoint son
suppléant préfecture finalement la
candidate en marche l'emportent avec
51,29 % des suffrages 725 voilà sépare
de charles barrière une victoire serrée
mais largement suffisante pour les
militants qui attendent impatiemment
leur candidate à montbard
élu également de la majorité
présidentielle dans la troisième
circonscription de saône-et-loire celle
du nord-ouest du département
le sortant philippe baumel avait été
éliminé dès le premier tour
rémy rebeyrotte s'impose avec 55 4% des
voix devant le républicain charles
landry lui n'est pas un nouveau venu en
politique conseiller général maire
d'autun depuis 2001 une fonction qu'il
devra d'ailleurs quitté sylvain billau
en compagnie de christophe gaillard 57,6
% des voix sur la ville d'autun rémy
rebeyrotte est tout sourire
et il a de quoi les résultats des
différentes communes à gitana et le
placent en tête deux heures seulement
après la fermeture des bureaux de vote
rémy rebeyrotte sait qu'il est le
nouveau député de la 3e circonscription
de saône-et-loire très heureux de
représenter la république en marche très
très heureux de pouvoir apporter notre
voix dans la majorité présidentielle et
de faire en sorte que les projets du
président de la république puisse
avancer on sera vraiment en appui des
projets du président et du gouvernement
est donc évidemment je vous cache pas
notre émotion et et notre bonheur au
creusot chez les militants du parti des
républicains l'ambiance est toute autre
les résultats définitifs viennent de
tomber charles landes et battu de 3333
voix dans la mesure où nous avions
l'ensemble des formations politiques
contre nous nous avons fait
boa trappage au deuxième tour et puis je
crois que dès demain nous irons à la
reconstruction une scène politique parce
que on le voit dans les résultats
j'avais les trois exécutifs des trois
principales intercommunalités de saône
et loire qui ont soutenu le candidat en
marche et je crois qu'il faudra en tirer
les conséquences politiques dès demain
matin voix sur le non cumul des mandats
oblige une autre étape s'annonce pour
rémy rebeyrotte préparer sa succession à
la mairie d'autun est à la tête de la
communauté de communes du grand tournoi
en plus de yolaine de courson et rémy
rebeyrotte que nous venons de voir elle
a besoin
huit autres députés élus dans la
bourgogne pour la république en marche
devient député à 60 ans didier martin
adjoint au maire de dijon est élu dans
la première de côte-d'or issu du parti
radical de gauche il avait rejoint le
mouvement des manuels macron en mai 2016
ancienne vice-présidente du conseil
régional socialiste elle est professeur
d'anglais fadila khattabi rafle la mise
dans la troisième de côte-d'or terre
socialiste
elle devance son adversaire le front
national jean-françois bateliers à 63
ans et sa première élection didier
parris ancien sous préfet ancien
directeur de région succède à alain
suguenot dans la cinquième de côte-d'or
rathbone et son vignoble dans la nièvre
deux novices complet en politique
devienne député de la république en
marche à nevers perrine goulet ingénieur
dans une centrale nucléaire dont le
mandant patrice chéreau patron d'une
société d'ambulances c'est un inconnu
aussi du monde politique le jeune chef
d'entreprise benjamin dirks a bénéficié
lui aussi de la vague macro nist à mâcon
où ils l'emportent avec 57% des voix
devant jean patrick courtois mer et
l'air de mâcon à chalon le maquereau
nist raphaël gobain gagne le pari de son
parachutage dans la 5e circonscription
à 44 ans cet avocat parisien beau fils
de dominique perben conquiert son
premier mandat en totalisant 55 % des
voix
et puis dernière personnalité qui va
siéger à l'assemblée nationale michel
crouzet chef d'entreprise conseillère à
départementale elle est désormais député
de l'yonne dans la troisième
circonscription où elle a battu le
candidat fn julien odoul un nom
coût circuler pendant cette campagne
dans la 5e circonscription de saône et
loire vous l'évoquiez les as et celui de
dominique perben ancien maire de chalon
sur saône pendant près de 20 ans raphaël
gauvin et donc son beau-fils à ceux qui
ont reproché un parachutage en bourgogne
dominique perben rétorque qu'il est
arrivé dans la région dans les mêmes
conditions il ya 35 ans ça me rappelle
des souvenirs
quand je suis arrivé à chalon en 1983 je
faisais ma campagne en regardant le plan
de la ville et puis après pendant vingt
ans j'ai fait quelques petites choses
pour chalon voilà donc tout ça c'est des
choses qui sont des critiques qui
passeront très très vite j'en suis
convaincu il a par rapport à ce que
j'étais à l'époque un gros avantage
c'est que lui il a vécu 20 ans ici et
toute sa famille est ici donc il connaît
bien la région et je suis convaincu que
ses qualités de travail vont lui
permettre de très vite se mettre dans le
coup les dossiers et nous continuons
notre liste des nouveaux venus à
l'assemblée nationale avec deux élus
aussi pour la droite elsa non
saône-et-loire josiane corps de loups
permettent effectivement républicain de
récupérer le charolais brionnais cette
pharmacienne pourtant distancé au
premier tour assure resserrer les rangs
dans cette circonscription fluctuante en
fonction des alternances et c'est dans
une autre circonscription instable celle
de l'yonne la deuxième de l'yonne
qu'andré villiers a créé la surprise
donné perdant à l'issue du premier tour
le président centriste du département
est parvenu à s'imposer au second tour
en recueillant 54% des voix contre 45
pour son adversaire jean yves caullet
figure locale du ps passé sous la
bannière en marche
andré villiers touché par le non cumul
des mandats en tant que président udi du
conseil départemental de l'yonne
il a confirmé hier soir sur france 3
préparer sa succession
dans un mois précisément eh bien je
devrais quitter effectivement la
présidence du conseil départemental
j'annonce que je resterai conseiller
départemental du canton de joe la ville
c'est ma base de départ j'y suis
extrêmement attachée et
je ne peux pas évidemment vous répondre
sur l'identité de celui qui me succédera
mais les choses vont se gérer au sein de
la majorité départementale aux régions
de la précédente assemblée il ne reste
donc que trois députés il faut dire que
ça ne se représentait pas que trois ont
été éliminés au premier tour 2 hier soir
trois gardes donc leur siège oui c'est à
l'arraché que guillaume larrivé a tenu
son bastion d'auxerre dans la première
de l'yonne de justesse comme en 2012
pour sa première élection
1800 voix seulement devant le candidat
dans marche paulo da silva moreira il
sauve sa peau aussi rémi de la terre est
élu en côte d'or dans la première
circonscription
le candidat dans marche françois de ces
lui a pourtant donné du fil à retordre
sortant du premier tour en ballottage
favorable 7 points devant
et puis en saône et loire dans
l'ancienne circonscription d'arnaud
montebourg la socialiste cécile
untermaier on l'a dit sort victorieuse
du duel qui l'opposait à la marcheuse
catherine gabrel avec un peu plus de 54%
des voix mis en danger après le premier
tour guillaume larrivé était passé à
l'offensive qualifiant sur france 3 son
adversaire d'inutiles ou de godillots
une campagne violente couronnée de
succès johan albrecht quand un césar qui
en arrivent et savoure sa victoire
pour la deuxième fois il remporte la
1ère circonscription de belote avec
52,59 % des suffrages
1800 voix d'avancé principalement issus
des zones rurales de la circonscription
j'ai été vu en 2012 malgré la vague rose
monsieur hollande je suis réélue en 2017
malgré ce tsunami macro nist je vois la
démonstration de la confiance et de la
fidélité qui m'est donnée par une
majorité des habitants de notre
territoire de l'yonne les républicains
remportent deux des trois
circonscriptions du département grâce à
un excellent report de voix en
ballottage défavorable à l'issue du
premier tour guillaume larrivé à
rattraper plus de 4 points et demi de
retard à la plus grande joie de ses
supporteurs enfin enfin on attendait les
mérites guillaume c'est à laurent depuis
dix ans participent heures vraiment
activement auprès de guillaume et là
c'est vrai que c'était pas gagné mais on
a gagné porte-à-porte courrier aux
habitants dans chaque village ses
équipes se sont fortement mobilisés
pendant l'entre-deux-tours plus que ravi
nous l'avons soutenu soutenu énormément
et aujourd'hui on est ravi d'avoir une
super me réussit l'abstention plus élevé
qu'au premier tour a également joué en
faveur du candidat républicain qui
remporta une victoire plus nette qu'en
2012 la bourgogne passe donc de 10
députés socialistes à une seule cécile
untermaier sauve l'honneur du ps elle
repart pour un deuxième mandat pour elle
son travail a payé
face à une candidate inexpérimenté
michel gillot communs disposent pour
catherine gabrel cette énumération est
flatteuse mais trompeuse si la commune
de royer dont elle est maire la porte en
tête cela restera parmi les exceptions
de cette soirée
car à 40 km d'ici dans la permanence
louhannaise de cécile untermaier les
bons résultats tombent les uns après les
autres
certains surprennent même la députée
sortante ontex était très très compliqué
moi je
je suis très étonné même des résultats
très heureuse de voir qu'on tourne en
tête dans des communes rurales auquel je
suis très attaché et puis même dans des
villes de droite qui finalement parce
part car ce vote acceptent de travailler
avec moi et de me faire confiance à
royer catherine garde elle s'est vite
rendu à l'évidence
l'éthique est en marche n'a pas suffi ça
a été vraiment une expérience
enrichissante et je n'aurai pas de
regret je reste en marche parce que je
trouve que c'est un mouvement qui est
qui vaut la peine qu'on qu'on le
soutienne
donc je reste en marche je suis persuadé
que ben il faut le temps que ça
s'installe mais j'espère que dans cinq
ans on définitive avec 3000 voix devant
sur sa concurrente la victoire de cécile
une paire meilleurs et même bien plus
large qu'en 2012 face à arnaud danjean
et cette victoire la députée sortante la
tribu à son action de député c'est la
seule explication possible c'est
effectivement que je les ai convaincus
pendant ces cinq ans vient de l'ags la
qualité du travail que nous pouvions
mener ensemble
moi je m'en réjouis je les félicite j'ai
une pensée bien sûr pour mon adversaire
parce que je sais que c'est pas facile
et je peux lui dire que c'est encore
plus difficile de perdre quand on a déjà
le mandat frédéric cannard le binôme de
la candidate vient de recevoir un texto
d'arnaud montebourg qui fait dans la
métaphore sportive de fait
cécile une paire meyer a bel et bien
réussi ça remonte à 2 il a beaucoup été
dit après le premier tour que l'éthique
est en marche permettait d'être élu à
coup sûr le mouvement est d'ailleurs en
tête partout en bourgogne je me tourne
vers vous lilian melet il est donc d
exception comment les expliquer on
attendait un tsunami on a eu une vague
et la différence c'est qu'avec une vague
parfois on voit le fond autrement dit
les spécificités de la circonscription
et des candidats n'ont pas été
totalement submergé et on peut tenter de
trouver des explications dans les cinq
circonscriptions bourguignonne ou la
république en marche a échoué il ya
d'abord la sempiternelle prime aux
sortants l'implantation qui amortit les
chocs
c'est le cas des républicains rémy de
lattes en côte-d'or et guillaume larrivé
dans l'yonne et de la socialiste cécile
untermaier en saône et loire jean yves
caullet dans l'yonne était lui aussi
sortant mais il avait été élu pour le ps
avait exercé son mandat pour le ps
avant de rejoindre emmanuel macron en
début d'année un virage abondamment
utilisé par son adversaire andré
villiers qui par ailleurs en tant que
président du conseil départemental et
bénéficier d'une autre forme de prime au
sortant
autre point commun dans ces échecs on
trouve les trois candidats du modem
françois de cei en côte d'or vincent
chauvet et catherine gabrel en saône et
loire dont les candidatures ont été
annoncés après les autres après le coup
de pression de françois bayrou alors que
d'autres personnes localement revendiqué
cette investiture et l'ont parfois
contestées enfin ces circonscriptions
sont pour la plupart rural est
incontestablement dans ces zones une
part importante des électeurs fn du
premier tour se sont reportés sur les
candidats de droite dont certains
prévoyants n'avait pas appelé à faire
barrage à marine le pen à la
présidentielle comme rémi delattre et
guillaume larrivé des candidats moins
solides des adversaires bien en place
plus un électorat moins mobilisé de
mauvais report des voix vous mélangez et
ça fait 10 sur 15
il était question également fière de
reconstruction de renouvellement de faim
deux blocs politiques actions et analyse
des principales forces politiques
de la région ps lr front national et
france insoumise c'était hier dans notre
soirée spéciale sur france 3 il ya une
volonté de changement des têtes ça se
produit les électeurs en ont ras-le-bol
de voir toujours les mêmes qu'on n'a pas
envie de voter pour des gens qui sans
guerre entre eux donc le parti
socialiste étaient les frondeurs et les
spas frondeurs donc ça donne pas envie
on a été sanctionné pour ça on a été
sanctionnés aussi sur le bilan du
quinquennat sans doute donc il faut
reconstruire
je suis également profondément convaincu
que la gauche ne sera pas durablement
effacés il nous faut donc la réinventer
nous faut reconstruire un parti d'un
nouveau type un nouveau parti politique
parti socialiste était broyée dans
l'exercice du pouvoir
une autre étape va s'écrire maintenant
et moi ce qui m'a beaucoup interrogé
c'est que quand on regarde le premier
tour des élections présidentielles nous
avions quatre blocs politiques qui
semblait se dessiner avec une proportion
je dirais très proche c'est sensible et
il n'existe plus ces quatre blocs
n'existe plus jeunes et pour autant les
convictions semble être quand même
en général on garde les mêmes à trois
semaines déclare moi je remarque
aujourd'hui quand même que le front
national a su avoir des élus
pratiquement six ou huit j'ai pas le
chiffre exact
alors que tous les pronostics voyez
marine le pen très bas et les candidats
du front national c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a une vraie force de
résistance à l'assemblée nationale par
ticket donne deuxième tour de la
présidentielle est certain que le mode
de scrutin est pas très démocratique
et moi je suis pour la proportionnelle
intégrale on a réussi à avoir un groupe
parlementaire de l'apéro et j'ai vu les
premières estimations seraient à 19
députés france insoumise avec
certainement aussi une dizaine d'amis
communiste et peut-être certains
socialistes
donc on va avoir un réel pouvoir à
l'assemblée une réelle présence et
pouvoir faire des propositions sur notre
programme l'avenir en commun même si là
la majorité obtenue par le président de
la république est un peu moins forte que
ce qui était attendu
il a une majorité absolue il a les
moyens maintenant de mener
le projet de réforme de la france et je
pense que c'est ça qu'il faut retenir
qui est très important c'est que les
français ils ont envie effectivement que
cette réforme se met en oeuvre tous les
résultats sont à retrouver en ligne sur
notre site internet une seule adresse
bfc point france 3 point fr vous y lirez
aussi en détail le parcours de vos
nouveaux élus vous pourrez aussi revoir
nos émissions spéciales d'hier soir sur
notre site bfc point france 3 point fr à
partage également sur les réseaux
sociaux tout de suite la météo et
attention la bourgogne concerné par la
vague de grosses chaleurs annoncées dans
les prochaines heures sans air pour nous
rafraîchir retour aux résultats des
législatives dans l'édition nationale du
12/13 réactions et des bas ensuite en
bourgogne franche comté à nouveau à
12h55 avec et jean christophe gallais 10
parmi nous invitait de nouveaux députés
josiane corneloup élue républicaine en
saône et loire
didier paris et didier martin pour la
république en marche en côte d'or rendez
vous ce soir pour le 19/20 très bel
après midi sur france 3
[Musique]